we have been covering the hit that
tourism in the United States has taken
under Donald Trump and I was thinking to
myself if world tourism were down and US
tourism were also down it might have
nothing to do with Donald Trump right we
can't say if tourism is down everywhere
among the United States or including the
United States that it's because of
Donald Trump but we now have a new
report showing that actually worldwide
in the developed world there has been a
boom in travel and yet the United States
and one other country turkey in what's
considered the developed world have seen
a decrease in travel and it's becoming
increasingly clear that many elements of
Donald Trump being president of the
United States are really hurting the
hospitality industry big time partially
because people are saying if Trump's
president I don't want to go to the
United States the US Travel Association
has confirmed that not only has travel
been down under Donald Trump to the
United States they project that in 2018
it's going to end up down even more and
when you look at the numbers in terms of
percentages they're not obviously huge
US tourism was twelve point nine percent
of world tourism when Trump took over
the presidency it was down to 12% last
year it's down to 11 point 7 percent in
2018 but what you have to consider is
given the size of this pie of worldwide
tourism or tourism to develop nations
0.5% represents a massive amount of
money and a huge number of tourism
dollars and a significant number of
tourism and hospitality hospitality
related jobs and what every indication
points to are a few different factors
number one the travel ban itself is
keeping some people out of the country
right like some people can't come to the
United States because of the travel ban
the existence of the travel ban is
making more people choose not to come to
the United States Trump's policy on
climate change is keeping people in some
parts of the world out of the United
States Trump's attacks on other
countries including some of our allies
are keeping other people from traveling
to the United States and meanwhile this
is not a worldwide phenomenon
tourism is up in the entire developed
world again except
the United States and in Turkey Spain
Australia Canada on and on and on
significant increases in tourism and at
the bottom the United States down six
percent overall and Turkey
down six point seven percent overall
Turkey partially is because a number of
countries have travel warnings about the
safety of going to that country so when
you look at that and you say here's the
list of developed countries for the
purposes of this study Turkey has
significant security issues that
countries are warning people about
against traveling there you see that it
is indeed Donald Trump that is a
disaster for the American tourism
industry and this is an example of
something that takes a while to fix if
Trump left office tomorrow you don't
immediately get tourism back we've seen
graduate students decrease applications
to come to graduate school in the United
States these are processes planning a
trip sometimes months ahead of time
applying to and moving to another
country to go to school these things
take a while and it's going to be a
while even after Donald Trump leaves
office for this dude reverse course and
I don't think they would even care right
Republicans by and large wouldn't care
because if you're visiting the US from a
foreign country chances are you going to
the cities right maybe you're going to
New York City or maybe you go into like
Hawaii which is another blue area so
that doesn't that's not their voter base
they wouldn't care so much maybe they
say we don't really want people from
other countries coming here I mean
Sweden and Norway would be fine of
course but we don't necessarily want
these individuals in the country they
could overstay visas they might be the
same types of people that were trying to
deport on a regular basis and even
though this is bad for our economy it's
sort of is the logical conclusion for
this insular anti-immigrant xenophobic
jingoistic agenda that we've been
covering on the behalf of the Trump
administration for nearly two years now
and if the idea was stop people from
wanting to come to the United States at
least when it comes to people coming for
tourism it actually seems to be working
although I don't know whether that's
actually what the Republicans in
Congress in the Senate and in the Oval
Office intended let's talk about Alex
Jones the Alex Jones free speech hate
speech conspiracy theorist Fiasco has
just exploded because YouTube has banned
Alex Jones altogether
they've ended his channel's existence on
YouTube if you go to the Alex Jones
YouTube channel right now you will
merely see a message saying quote this
account has been terminated for
violating YouTube's Community Guidelines
Spotify as I told you had pulled some
podcast episodes Facebook had removed
some video content by Alex Jones I told
you yesterday that iTunes removed the
audio podcasts altogether and now the
big boy one of the massive moneymakers
for Alex Jones has ended his channel
altogether on YouTube and this story has
just grown and grown over the last 24
hours
and I want to do the censorship piece
justice so I want to get into more
detail about this today than I did
yesterday so first of all so that we
have all the information
why did YouTube ban Alex Jones channel
YouTube's Terms prohibit hate speech and
harassment YouTube says Alex Jones was
publishing both of those things which
clips exactly is not totally clear but
there's plenty of a fodder there right
claiming the parents of Sandy Hook
school shooting victims were crisis
actors promoting Pizza Gate conspiracy
theories which led to the harassment of
the staff and management and ownership
at that comic ping-pong Pizza whatever
it's called blaming the parkland
shooting on the wrong person there's a
very long list here and that is why
YouTube says it has banned the channel
entirely Joan's reaction is that he was
the victim of a quote globalist
Deathstar intent on banning
conservatives from platforms like
YouTube and social media he says you can
help him fight that censorship by buying
more of those bogus supplements that he
sells so oh sure
never waste a good opportunity to make
some money so now let's get into the
analysis yesterday I made clear that
this isn't a free speech issue in in the
legal sense since Spotify and iTunes and
YouTube aren't the government okay
I also made clear that these websites
have Community Guidelines and they
determine if you have violated them so
what happened here is totally legal and
in the same way that I've been deme on
it
highest or head videos limited overtime
by these platforms so has Alex Jones the
other argument is okay fine David the
companies have Terms of Service and they
can make these decisions but these
companies are so big and they have so
much control over eyeballs that they're
unique in some way it's not like your
local paper saying they're no longer
gonna accept letters to the editor from
Alex Jones the idea is these companies
are so big and control such market share
that they are tastemakers that's not
even the right word I really need a
bigger word and thus they can't just say
we're gonna block Alex Jones if your
argument is that they're too big to be
bound by the or to be have the same
freedoms that normal smaller businesses
should you have maybe the problem is
that they got so big in the first place
except I don't hear conservatives trying
to prevent companies like YouTube from
getting as big as they have gotten I
mean it's a fair argument to make right
because YouTube does seem like it's
becoming a monopoly there isn't a clear
competitor to it Facebook you can say
the same thing maybe to a lesser degree
but if you want to make those a public
commodity you have to do that because
you believe in the principle not just
because you're against Alex Jones being
banned from those platforms and not
starting to talk about it
only when Alex Jones has been banned
from those platforms so that's the legal
situation now that being said I don't
like this I don't like this and I want
to explain to you why I do like the fact
that Alex Jones is disgusting vile
dangerous material is going to be less
accessible so if that's what YouTube
wants to do legally I don't have a
problem with it but I believe that the
spirit of platforms like YouTube should
be if it's not illegal then allow it
advertisers have to have the right to
say we don't want our ads showing up on
the Alex Jones channel if that's their
prerogative if that's what they want
there shouldn't be child porn allowed
there shouldn't be direct threats
against specific people that one's
actually kind of borderline because the
pizza gate stuff from Alex Jones
arguably did lead to threats against
specific people but the theme is even if
this is okay to do by YouTube
I don't think it's a good direction the
views of people like Alex Jones should
be ostracized and discredited ideally
ignored they should be so obviously
ridiculous that they have no impact as a
policy I opted on the side of allow it
if it's legal because once you start
picking and choosing it's about whether
you like the choices YouTube or Facebook
or whoever makes now this is blurry and
complex because I do think that these
platforms have a responsibility to
police content responsibly if
individuals are being targeted or
harassed if the content is criminal then
they do have a responsibility to deal
with that and they can make these
decisions but I would prefer in the
absence of illegal content for
individual pieces of content that are
offending the policy [ __ ] ID lines
Terms of Service to be removed rather
than entire channels in addition once
you start doing this people are going to
point out and rightly so
YouTube is filled with horrible channels
channels that have been pointed out
lately which have not been blocked or
banned including channels where parents
do horrible things to their kids a
borderline and including child abuse and
all sorts of other stuff so part of this
isn't just the content of the videos but
it's the relative impact and the PR
around them and that's where it starts
to get dicey because it became
groupthink among these different
platforms - all at the same time say
that's gonna do it for Alex Jones so
legally I don't see a problem but I
don't like this and I recognize that
just because it's happening to Alex
Jones now and not me it could happen to
me
even if I've not put up a legal content
merely because of the sort of shifting
interpretation of what the community
guidelines are yeah I really hate that
pile on effects that we see from some of
these platforms like because Spotify
takes down some of his episodes that
means that Facebook and YouTube have to
ban them even though those platforms for
the longest time expressed that they
want to keep Alex Jones's channel up out
of the principle of free speech so
that's a little bit disconcerting and I
know people are gonna write in to me Pat
and say David are you defending alex
jones or are you defending his content
no i'm not doing either i think that the
content as I said is vile depraved and
disgust
and it's anything that leads to fewer
people seeing it is a good thing in
terms of the ends the means are
something I worry about because it is
open to significant subjectivity once
you say it's not illegal content and I
do understand why YouTube did it I get
why iTunes did it this is not only a PR
liability but if Alex Jones loses a
lawsuit against the Sandy Hook family
soon which might these platforms could
be worried about legal liability for
having allowed the offending content
once again what I want to circle back to
is the analysis from yesterday stands
which is this is what it looks like when
businesses make decisions that are best
for them just because YouTube is huge
doesn't mean they have to carry it
unless of course it's determined that in
on the basis of the 1966 Supreme Court
case Evans V Newton it's a private
company that is endowed with sort of
pseudo governmental powers or as an
agency of the state because they are so
big that's not been determined here
legally speaking but in the meantime the
problem is people will start to say if
this one why not that one people have
been emailing me about steven crowder
saying David in a lot of his videos he's
sort of bullying people and harassing
people it isn't this over the line isn't
it hate and that's why it gets very
complex yeah it's the classic slippery
slope argument and maybe you could say
the same thing about us that maybe we're
next and you know we don't defame people
here in the David Pakman show and we
don't issue any threats of violence we
tend to save that for the bonus show or
that course you know it could raise some
red flags oftentimes slippery slopes
should be resisted when they don't make
sense other times you have to consider
is there actually any protection against
the slippery slope and I think that this
is a borderline case for sure we've had
a massive break in the Trump Russia
Fiasco and there is massive news to
report to you today which is that
President Donald Trump is now admitting
that yeah the purpose of his campaign
meeting with Russians that infamous day
in Trump Tower was specifically to
obtain
hurt on Hillary Clinton during the
campaign they worked with Russia
President Trump admitting this in a
coordinated way with a scheduled meeting
meant to get damaging information for
the purposes of helping Donald Trump
defeat Hillary Clinton in the 2016
presidential campaign the circle now is
almost complete and remember we go back
to where the story started there was no
Russia story there were no meetings then
the right started shifting to collusion
wouldn't actually be a crime anyway and
then in the last couple of weeks last
week I reported to you that Donald
Trump's own attorney shifted from there
was no collusion there was no
coordination to I can't find in the
criminal code where it even mentions
collusion that was rudy giuliani last
week and now for the first time we have
Donald Trump personally admitting that
this Trump Tower meeting on June 9 2016
with Russian lawyer Natalia vessel
Mnet's kaya was not about adoptions it
was to get dirt on Hillary Clinton this
is working with Russia on the
presidential campaign here is Trump's
tweet from Sunday morning which was in
response it appears to a Washington Post
article pointing out that Donald Trump
jr. might be in serious legal trouble in
this entire thing that seemed to set
Donald Trump off who said quote fake
news reporting a complete fabrication
that I am concerned about the meeting my
wonderful son Donald had in Trump Tower
this was a meeting to get information on
an opponent totally legal and done all
the time in politics and it went nowhere
I did not know about it so Trump still
denying that he knew about it pretty
clear at this point that he did talked
about that last week claiming that it's
done all the time well not with foreign
countries we've heard from Democrats and
Republicans alike that if they were
approached by a foreign country offering
something like this they wouldn't set up
a meeting they would call the FBI which
we know the Trump administration did not
do but the big news here it's important
not to lose the thread because Trump
wants to focus on it was legal and it
was done it's done all the time this is
the first admission
Donald Trump that the meeting took place
with the goal of getting damaging
information about his opponent Hillary
Clinton this is something of value from
a foreign power and then of course aside
from the meeting itself this incident
led to lies from Trump about his
involvement after the fact he dictated
the response letter to this incident and
the reporting of it by the New York
Times after initially saying that he
didn't dictate that letter and the
number two lies about the subject of the
meeting are now confirmed I'd up by
Donald Trump we were initially told it
was about adoptions which in a sense it
kind of was
so the Magnitsky Act is related to
sanctions and adoptions is sort of quid
pro quo for it's an intimated quid pro
quo that if the hillary dirt helps trump
win then the future trump administration
would look at rewarding Russia with
eased sanctions now we know because
Trump himself said it this was about
dirt on Hillary period Trump's campaign
was offered things of value by Russia
and they accepted the offer the only
step remaining to fully close the circle
would be proof of what Trump's former
personal lawyer alleged last week which
is that Trump knew about the meeting in
advance Trump still claims that he
didn't know about that we don't know if
we're eventually going to get proof of
that or not all of the circumstantial
and timing evidence suggests Trump knew
ahead of time and in addition to that
the question of whether anything came of
it the narrative so far from people who
have been caught lying multiple times
has been we had the meeting we were
promised dirt on Hillary we wanted the
dirt on Hillary but we didn't ultimately
get it that's what we were told we
didn't ultimately get the dirt on
Hillary what's going to be next you know
we got some dirt and it was patriotic
because it kept Hillary out of the White
House because Russia wanted epic make
America great again
winner Trump to win that's the only part
of the circle left to be filled
potentially hey I mean these guys Donald
Trump jr. Jared Kushner they had never
worked on a political campaign before
there was their first time and sometimes
when you dip your toe into the water of
a political campaign you accidentally
commit a few
federal offenses that well anyone what
are the legal implications this could
make the Donald Trump's admission that
the the point of this meeting was to
obtain dirt on his opponent from a
foreign country this could make the
meeting itself conspiracy with a foreign
country this could make the lies about
the meeting obstruction of justice
conspiracy and false statements to the
feds if false statements to the feds
were made and it appears that they
probably were at this point given what
Donald Trump jr. reportedly told
investigators and and in a hearing
rather he is not necessarily said that
to investigators and what Trump is now
admitting the meeting was for
potentially multiple federal crimes by
many people implied by this tweet by
Donald Trump but the big question
remains which is will anyone and
specifically Trump pay for it and the
answer if you don't go out in November
and vote is probably not and by the way
still some people emailing me saying
there's no Russia story but very few at
this point very few people still
emailing me saying there's no Russia
story
lastly we always have to ask is this a
strategy or is this stupidity Donald
Trump saying this on Twitter it's never
clear it's a pot of possible strategy to
create chaos with the contradictions it
could be trying to get out in front of
the story before it breaks in a more
damaging way it could be idiocy and
ignorance it could be a combination of
all of these but what I returned to
every time is look at the evolution
there was no meeting there was a meeting
to discuss adoptions there was a meeting
to discuss dirt on Hillary but we didn't
get the dirt and the next logical step
if these are all lies is we did get dirt
but nothing illegal took place or we did
get dirt but we didn't ultimately need
it because Hillary's campaign was such a
disaster every single week we learn
about more lies that have been told to
us the Trump war on the media and a free
press continues and the theme is this
phrase the enemy of the people the enemy
of the people is the phrase that keeps
coming up about the press by Donald
Trump and by his cronies and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the White House press
secretary was asked directly a number of
times during a press briefing late last
week as the weekend was kicking off is
the press the enemy of the people as far
as she is concerned and
or as far as the Trump administration is
concerned she was asked this by the
press at a press briefing and one of the
ways this is being written up is Sarah
Huckabee Sanders refuses to deny that
the press is the enemy of the American
people what you have to understand and
I'm gonna play a clip for you here is
that when she said time and again I'm
here to represent the president's views
and the president has made his views
clear it's more than a non-denial that
they see the press as the enemy of the
American people
it is the acknowledgment that they see
the press as the enemy of the American
people she refused to say no multiple
times and said the Trump Trump is
already spoken about this it's a
slightly longer clip I'm gonna play for
you because I want you to pay attention
to the dynamics of how there are
multiple opportunities for her to just
say no no big picture I or the Trump
administration whoever she's speaking
for at the time don't see the press as
the enemy of the American people she
doesn't do that she does believe and she
is restating that the Trump
administration does believe that the
press is the enemy of the American
people let's take a look Jim on Sarah's
question from NPR she asked you about
Ivanka Trump's statement that the press
is not the enemy of the people and she
asked you whether or not the press is
the enemy of the people you read off a
laundry list of your concerns about the
press and things that you feel like are
misreported but you did not say that the
press is not the enemy of the people and
I think it would be a good thing if you
were to say right here at this briefing
that the press the people who are
gathered in this room right now right
doing their jobs every day asking
questions of officials like the ones you
brought forward earlier or not the enemy
of the people I I think we deserve that
the president has made his position
known I also think it's ironic I'm
trying to answer your question I
politely waited and I even called on you
despite the fact that you interrupted me
while calling on your colleague I said
it's ironic sure which was
why I interrupted I'm trying to view if
you finish if you would not mind letting
me have a follow-up that would be fine
but it's ironic Jim that not only you
and the media attacked the president for
his rhetoric when they frequently lower
the level of conversation in this
country repeatedly repeatedly the media
resorts to personal attacks without any
content other than to incite anger the
media has attacked me personally on a
number of occasions including your own
Network said I should be harassed as a
life sentence that I should be choked
ice officials are not welcomed in their
place of worship and personal
information is shared on the Internet
when I was hosted by the Correspondents
Association of which almost all of you
are members of you brought a comedian
out to attack my appearance and call me
a traitor to my own gender in fact as I
know and as far as I know I'm the first
press secretary in the history of the
United States that's required Secret
Service protection the media continues
to ratchet up the verbal assault against
the President and everyone in this
administration and certainly we have a
role to play but the media has a role to
play for the discourse in this country
as well if I may follow up excuse me you
did not say in the course of those
remarks that you just made that the
press is not the enemy of the people are
we to take it from what you just said we
all get put through the wringer we all
get put in the meat grinder in this town
and you're no exception and I'm sorry
that that happened to you I wish that
that had not happened but for the sake
of this this room the people who are in
this room this democracy this country
all the people around the world are
watching what you're saying Sarah and
the White House for the United States of
America the presidency should not refer
to us as the enemy of the people his own
daughter acknowledges that and all I'm
asking you to do sir is to acknowledge
that right now and right
I appreciate your passion I share it
I've addressed this question I've
addressed my personal feelings I'm here
to speak on behalf of the president he's
made his comments clear so Sarah was
that a yes or no one presses the enemy
of the American people she talks about
how she hasn't liked reports about her
and satires of her but that's not the
question the question is about the role
and the perception of the media by this
administration and if you're a defender
of the Constitution if you believe in
checks and balances the answer to this
question should be and it really has to
be a completely unequivocal and
definitive no of course the press is not
the enemy of the American people this
wasn't a vague question open to
interpretation it's Jim Acosta from CNN
who asked the question here he was
specific
she still filibustered didn't answer and
in fact she's saying yes the press is
the enemy I speak for the president she
said that's what Trump has said and
that's what the position of the
administration appears to be and
bringing up satirical pieces done about
her I guess it's either to distract her
to try to get some sympathy she might be
a more sympathetic character if she
stopped telling depraved and horrific
lies to the American people day in and
day out but it continues to amaze me how
the party that claims to be against the
safe spaces and the trigger warnings is
regularly and so easily triggered and
what's dangerous and vile about this
position is that it is even worse than
what we've seen from some of the worst
Republicans I don't romanticize Bush you
know that rap but even Bush would say
directly when he had big conflicts with
individual media outlets a free press is
necessary and healthy to democracy it's
such a simple thing to say if you
believe in it and they're just not
saying it because they don't believe in
it we also know that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders calling card is off you see a
Shinto yeah so she could have walked
that tightrope and done it a little bit
better right between appeasing President
Trump and also reassuring the importance
of a free press like she could have said
that most outlets are totally fine but
there are some liberal reporters out
there doing a horrible job and names
them for example like she could have
done both things she could have played
both sides there like she normally does
she decided not to go with I don't know
if
specific reporters would be walking the
tie probe necessarily but the big
picture is creeping authoritarianism and
when it's all said and done either in
2020 or in 2024 I hope that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is remembered for what
she's become which is one of the most
disgusting participants in this aberrant
administration and aberrant not on
policy but in terms of it's just
fundamental and basic disrespect for the
base tenets of the foundation of the
United States of America send me your
thoughts if you're as concerned as I am
about the battle against the press I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show let's
talk about the word collusion the word
collusion has come up surprisingly
frequently on political programs for the
last year and a half and recently I've
been telling you how the narrative
around Russian collusion has shifted
drastically from there was no collusion
to collusion wouldn't be illegal first
it was just right-wing media we heard on
Fox and Friends like a year ago
collusions not actually a crime more
recently it was Donald Trump's lawyer
Rudy Giuliani who started saying I don't
even know where collusion exists in the
criminal code and then over the weekend
we finally got to Donald Trump himself
who admitted that yeah we intended to
work with Russia to get damaging
information about Hillary Clinton at
that Trump Tower meeting but the
argument is it wasn't illegal so one of
the stories is the moving of the
goalposts that's a big part of the story
and I've already explained to you how
just because collusion doesn't show up
by name in the criminal code colluding
with a foreign country can encompass
many crimes receiving things of value
from foreign countries for the purposes
of elections obstruction of justice
conspiracy campaign finance violations
there's this very long list of actual
codified crimes that could fall under
the umbrella of collusion but let's put
that aside for a second let's skip the
semantic argument about whether
collusion is the crime or merely
describes the crime because Donald Trump
has actually already said he believes
collusion is a crime there's a really
good piece in The Washington Post by
Aaron Blake which points this out and it
points out that if collusion isn't a
crime
why has Donald
Trump been insisting for months now or
maybe even meat even even longer than
that that Hillary Clinton and the
Democrats colluded with Russia and
should be investigated if it's not a
crime to collude with Russia why would
Donald Trump suggest anybody be
investigated for it here's one recent
example from Donald Trump's Twitter
where he said quote collusion with
Russia was very real Hillary Clinton and
her team 100% colluded with the Russians
and so did Adam Schiff who is on tape
trying to collude with what he thought
was Russians to obtain compromising
material on Donald J Trump we already
know that Hillary Clinton paid through a
law firm eventually Kremlin connected
sources to gather info on Donald Trump
collusion is very real with Russia but
only with Hillary and the Democrats and
we should demand a full investigation as
Aaron Blake points out one would launch
an investigation into Hillary colluding
with Russia
if illegal activity was suspected if
it's collusion with Russia
that's suspected and that's not a crime
why would you start an investigation
into Hillary's collusion with Russia
this isn't a one-off from Donald Trump
it's happened time and again
June 8th Trump suggested Democrats
should be investigated for collusion and
obstruction of justice July 29th Donald
Trump tweeted why is Muller only
appointing angry Dems some of whom have
worked for crooked Hillary others
including himself have worked for Obama
and why isn't Muller looking at all of
the criminal activity and real Russian
collusion on the Democrat side Podesta
dossier if it's not a crime why would
you suggest Mulder look into it Donald
Trump even said in an interview that
collusion is corruption and thus it
warrants investigation he made a huge
deal out of it take a look at this this
is very big and frankly it's
unbelievable what was just found out is
that the Department of Justice the State
Department and the FBI colluded got
together to make Hillary Clinton look
less guilty and look a lot better than
she looks this is one of the big
breaking story
of our time in my opinion this shows
corruption at the highest level
collusion is corruption at the highest
level so of course who cares what the
legal argument is that Trump is making
legally he's clueless the real issue is
when you lie all the time the lies start
to conflict there was no Russian
meddling and why didn't obey prevent the
Russian meddling because it started
under his watch wait wait if it didn't
happen what is there for Obama to
prevent collusion isn't a crime but
Hillary colluded and should be
investigated for it the bottom line is
that the primary idea continues to be I
didn't do it but if I did it wasn't a
crime but if others did it it is a crime
and they are the ones who should
actually be investigated and sadly it's
stupid enough to possibly work because
it's already convinced endless endless
trumpets look at the discussions that
are taking place in the Trump friendly
recesses of the internet they have
fallen for this hook line and sinker
it's not a legal wise Trump saying
Hillary should be investigated for it
send me your thoughts you can also
discuss this on the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT quick break great interview
coming up next I have potentially good
news for you except that it's total BS
and what I mean is that there was a
report which if true would be really
great news which is that the NRA the
National Rifle Association the biggest
gun lobby in the United States they are
claiming to have such deep financial
trouble that they may be unable to
continue existing which would be lovely
news except it is very clearly an
attempt to garner more support and to
push back against what they feel is an
unfair case being made against an
insurance program of theirs by the New
York by New York State and all of this
information came from a document that
the NRA filed which Rolling Stone
obtained and what the NRA is filing says
is that because of a lawsuit that is
being brought against them by New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo a New York state
financial
regulators they have become victims of a
blacklisting campaign by the state and
have suffered tens of millions of
dollars in damages and what they claim
is they can't access basic financial
services that they need in order to
operate that they're facing quote
irrecoverable loss and irreparable farm
harm they say that they've lost
insurance coverage that they need for
day-to-day operations that some of their
physical offices are at risk that their
video streaming service and magazine may
have to shut down this is all fantastic
I can't imagine better news here but I
am very clear that these claims are
being completely exaggerated since they
are being made in a filing against New
York State they say that they've been
unfairly targeted by state regulators
over what the state claims is the
illegal sale of NRA branded insurance
for gun owners the NRA was offering this
insurance called carry guard and what
carry guard would do is if you are a gun
owner and member of the NRA and you
legally fire a gun and as a result of
legally firing that gun you incur legal
expenses carry guard NRA insurance will
reimburse you for those legal expenses
lovely little program that they have
isn't it so I think that if true this
would be great news I want the NRA to
disappear they exist to increase gun
sales they exist to make people afraid
of the world so that they go out and
they buy guns and now we are learning
that they also existed during the 2016
campaign to work as a conduit between
Russia and the Trump campaign funneling
tons of foreign money to Donald Trump
but do I believe even for a second that
the NRA is on the verge of disappearing
obviously not obviously not the NRA is
very clearly exaggerating the supposedly
dire state of their financial position
they're misrepresenting their financial
situation to get donations to turn
people against the state of New York
this is a stunningly well funded
organization and I don't believe it at
all that they are at risk yeah I too
think it's a fund raising plea
especially because Republic
are in control of the government now and
what helps the NRA is making the case
that the government is going to take
away your guns and they especially make
that case after like a mass shooting
sure because Republicans are in charge
of everything they can't effectively
communicate that case in the same way
that gun manufacturers have been
suffering when it comes to gun sales
partially because you don't have a
Democrat in the White House that the NRA
is saying he's about to take your guns
maybe the NRA has been suffering mildly
when it comes to membership and so on
and so forth but they've got as we
learned foreign money coming in they've
got domestic money coming in and this is
all a ploy to suggest that the New York
State lawsuit against them is unfair
interference in what the NRA does but
this is a PR campaign it's a bottom line
that's what it is the NRA is not a
responsible organization it's a
political organization it's a business
organization that works exclusively for
gun manufacturers to sell more guns in
more places and there's been a big
campaign on Twitter started to send the
NRA thoughts and prayers which of course
is a reference to how the NRA always
will send thoughts and prayers after
shootings which of course do nothing and
I think it's equally likely that
thoughts and prayers on Twitter won't do
anything for the NRA suppose it
fundraising woes which I would argue
barely barely exist so don't fall for
this although it would be something to
rejoice about if indeed the NRA went out
of business they're not going out of
business and this is just an attempt to
get more money out of people